you've got physics see things in front
of you I have got physical things in
front of me I'm gonna also got up here
but I'm hugely hugely excited about
unfortunate enough from our group I
really wish I could say it was from our
group we've been interest in this type
of thing for for many years so as you
can see it's his autonomous scanning
probe microscopy in situ tip
conditioning through machine learning
and this is from Bob Watkins group in
University of Alberta and it's a
phenomenal piece of work I'm why I think
it might be of interest to computer file
audience it could also be of interest
for sixty symbols audience but for this
in particular it's the basically
controlling the atomic structure of
matter through machine learning so it's
really the interface between physics and
computer science
first of all it's all about scanning
probe microscopy now I think we've
talked a little bit about scanning
called microscopy but in essence what we
have is a sharp tip preferably
atomically sharp with one atom sticking
out the end and that sounds really
difficult to do but in practice not that
difficult to do but is difficult to
control is just how many atoms stick out
the end and the arrangement of the atoms
at the end and that is really the bane
of any scanning probe microscope is life
but let's say we've managed to create
this we've got one off I'm sticking at
the end here's our surface here's our
sample you bring it in and you move it
so you're almost at the touching point
sometimes even at the contact point
whereby you have a very small separation
between the tip and the sample so what
we have is our sharp tip we put it in
really close to surface and we do that
using piezoelectric crystals actually
those barbecue lighter things that you
use where you click at the end pits or
electric crystals in those so you bring
it in really close with in an atomic
diameter or so and then you move it
across the surface and what you're
picking up on is the interaction item
right at the end of the tip with the
atoms at the surface so you move back
and forth back and forth and build up an
image that way it's a slow process but
it's a process that is incredibly
precise and we sacrifice speed for that
precision and the other great thing is
because it's a probe as well as imaging
what you can do is you can deliberately
try to manipulate the surface so you can
bring the tip in bond and try to pluck
atoms out for example or if there are
atoms absorb in the surface you can try
and slide them move them across and
we're now at the point where in many
cases we can slide out on some will
across the surface to spell out
different patterns but
but and there's a big bot as I said the
key thing here with scanning for
microscopy is controlling the structure
at the end of the probe and so we'll
start off we will take our tip and the
way we create our tip the first stage in
creating the tip is we put it into a
solution solution of sodium hydroxide
and all this is chemistry of the
computerphile audience pair with me you
actually down to a sharp point but
that's not good enough generally it's
not good enough then you put it in your
vacuum system you move it in you'd like
to be able to see atoms but most of the
time you don't see Allen so what do you
do well you apply a little voltage pulse
to try in jiggly atoms around at the end
of the probe or you play an increase in
the current and that can lead to effects
which will move the atoms around at the
end of the probe that doesn't work you
crush it gently in that doesn't work you
cross it a little bit further in that
doesn't work you drive it in half a
millimeter or so and push it around and
try to try to jiggle it around how'd you
know if it's worked very very good
question you go does this image look
good yeah what we really want to have is
as an image whereby what we're seeing is
the structure the surface and that this
has as little influence as possible so
what we really want to do is have a
sharper probe as possible because for
example if we have a probe that looks
like this where we've got a flat plane
where each one of these atoms will code
it potentially contribute to the image
that can lead to very confusing images
because you've got multiple different
imaging centers let's say we've
something like this so it comes in like
this to the surface where you've got an
atom here and an atom here and both of
those can contribute to the image and
sometimes it'll be tilted slightly and
this one can contribute more because
it's close to the surface but this one
can still contribute it's reasonably
close to the surface so those are double
tip images with a band after scanning
more probe microscope is life because
really what you want to do is to get
right down to that atomic level at the
moment what happens is students postdocs
researchers sit in the lab and they they
literally just trial and error push the
tip in to surface apply voltage pulses
try and coerce it into the state they
want and it's a massive bottleneck
massive massive BOTS like when in fact
what we'd want is a sort of ultra tuned
or an autofocus button where you get to
the end of the day you've you've
experiment
it's might have worked okay but perhaps
your tip is not in a good state and you
want to press a button which is
optimized probe and go home and then
come in the morning and do your proper
experiments instead of driving yourself
to distraction just pushing the tip in
to the surface to try and change the
structure of the tip and that's been a
long time coming scanning probe
microscopy has been around since the
early eighties and we're still at that
level many men Nottingham's no different
many many groups are still at that level
where it's a you know a PhD student in
their second year literally banging
their head against the table going
please work that's why this paper is so
important and it's it's it's really nice
so what they've done they've trained a
convolutional neural net and there are
many many good videos about your nets
and convolutional neural nets on
computer file Mike Pound has done a
number of really good videos I
thoroughly recommend them that's what
they've used they've managed to train it
to distinguish between when it's got a
double tip and when it's got a proper
single atom tip and they've gone that
extra step and they've modified the
probe so that it will recover the
structure you need to get good single
atom images where this is a really big
leap for Dhin for me it's really
exciting I'm slightly disappointed that
we didn't get that we've been working on
this type of problem for a number of
years actually another good reason why
it's good to do computer file video and
this actually with computer scientists
here in Nottingham and a number of years
back we try to employ what are called
evolutionary algorithms or genetic
algorithms to try to tune the probe that
way it worked okay it didn't work
particularly well all the time and the
way to go
obviously the next step the next
evolutionary stage and that was to go to
the machine learning side of things and
I actually had a summer intern working
on this last year but we just as I said
we were beaten to pip to the post the
great thing is is where it can go
because they've they've controlled the
probe and they've been going for a
particular atomic resolution but
actually sometimes particular if you
want to do chemistry let's use this one
actually sometimes that atoms sticking
at the end is what you need but
sometimes what you might actually need
just in terms of the chemistry in the
arrangement of the electrons if you
really want a minute
atoms you want to do chemistry computer
control chemistry you might actually
need a structure a bit more like this in
terms of how it bonds and how it
interacts with the surface the next step
in this is to not just give us a good
tip give us a tip with our particular
structure give us a tip with a
particular state and then we are really
not just controlling matter at the
atomic level we're controlling them
right down at a single chemical bond
level and in fact we're controlling the
right the quantum mechanical structure
of the tip when we go a little bit
further along these lines you know can
we actually just tell it we wanted to
build something like that we just wanted
you know can we get the computer to - as
long as that's within the laws of
physics that's our blueprint you know
and that might be a chunk of silicon can
we actually get it to build that if you
calibrate in a camera there are various
test images that you can use to
calibrate it you know the white balance
or focus or whatever is there an
equivalence in this that's effectively
what they know when they talk about a
single tip versus a double tip this is a
probe this is a sample so what we'd like
is that the radius of curvature the
sharpness of this is smaller than the
object we're actually imaging at the
surface so if we do that well as we
trace it across we'll map out an image
of what's happening at the surface
however that's just by symmetry exactly
equivalent to that so if you have a
relatively blunt tip like a double tip
or like a triple tap or a quadruple tip
or cluster and you got something sharp
at the surface like a single atom or a
single bond that sticks out of the
surface then what will happen is that
this will image this so this is our test
structure to come in to map it across to
the video process this is our test
structure this is allowing us to say
what's happening at the end of the probe
and that's exactly what they're doing in
this they have single bonds which are
sticking out at the surface when they
see these sort of ghost-like images it's
telling us about the structure the tip
rather than structure the surface and
then they control it accordingly so this
is or control it's built into the
experiment and you expose the plastic of
the surface in particular regions
according to the pattern and the
important thing is when this particular
polymer is exposed to light it becomes
soluble if the region